- I've drawn a small illustration.
(funky music)
I feel He-Man, it's an instinctive thing.
You do--
- I turn up and they think,
"My god, he looks so
like Michael Jackson,"
then I go (hums "Thriller").
- I think it looks quite
cozy being a smurf.
Looks like a fun life,
they all like each other,
and they're all happy and you know,
Smurfette's pretty hot, right?
- Just what I was thinkin'.
Come on!
- I just did a movie with John Nelson.
- I was gonna say, did you?
- Yeah, so I think it's gotta
be Breakfast Club for me.
- It's one of my favorite movies,
I've seen it 25 times.
Final frame in the movie.
I got chicken nuggets,
sweet and sour sauce,
and a chocolate sundae, please.
- There's a new Wolverine diet this year,
the movie's gonna look
pretty different this time.
- Isn't this what Hussain Bolt lives on?
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] My Little Pony.
- I used to watch it
with my little sister.
♫ My little pony, my little pony ♫
This is going viral already.
- See, you're so good at drawing,
I actually thought I was getting better.
- No man, that's rubbish.
- Because even though he can't eat pizza,
he's still pretty cool.
- I think E.T., I think
E.T. would be endearing,
whereas Mr. T--
- He'd bite you.
- Yeah, he might, you know,
mar the overall kind of,
he's a pretty brash guy, right?
- Trashformer.
Look at that, sounds right?
- [Voiceover] Oh! Oh!
- Is there anything more depressing
than a broken IKEA coffee table?
- No, because that's all I've know.
Because I've never really successfully
put something together from IKEA.
("Dancing Shoes")